-Senator,
welcome back to the show.
How are you?
-It's great
to be back with you, Seth.
You know, all things considered,
I'm well.
You know, when one in five
mothers in America
is describing her children
under the age of 12
as being hungry, I'm great
-I feel the same way
when you put it in perspective
I will say
it's a little strange.
This is the second time
you have been on the show
since we've left the studio.
Once, I talked to you
from my attic,
and now I join you
from my in-laws' house.
And I want to say, it seem
as though your colleagues
in the Capitol are getting
better about wearing masks
-Yes.
-But do you still try
to avoid them as much as
possible, given the opportunity?
Now that you have
a good reason to avoid them.
-I will tell you that I am still
very vigilant about wearing --
I'm now actually, I've started
to sometimes wear double masks
[ Laughs ]
-Mm-hmm.
-Like, the medical one,
you know, the blue one,
and then, you know, whatever
the cloth one is over.
Yeah, they're wearing --
since the President
started wearing a mask,
I've noticed many more peopl
are wearing masks.
So, that's interesting,
isn't it?
-Well, you know, it's more sad
than interesting because,
you know, President -- no matter
who the president is,
it's a reminder that they ca
set a good example,
and it's a shame
it took this long.
But I think what everybody
was saying is,
when the person who is in charge
does the right thing,
it's amazing how many people
will follow that lead.
-Right.
And you're exactly right.
I mean, that is the power
of leadership, right?
And it is -- it is incumbent
on a person who has been
elected a leader
to actually understand
the responsibilities
of leadership.
And, of course, Donald Trump
does not understand
the responsibilities
of leadership.
A real leader understands
that their strength is in
how they lift people up and no
how they beat people down,
and that is something
Donald Trump has never seeme
to understand
since he took office.
So that's why
I'm supporting Joe Biden.
-Someone who I would imagine
you believed
did understand leadership wa
your colleague John Lewis.
I know he's lying in state now
in the Capitol.
Can you speak about
the example he set
and your history with him?
-Yeah.
I remember having
many conversations with him,
but one in particular,
in his office,
which was like
a Civil Rights museum,
because he has just lived
a full life of service, right?
And from the time that he wa
a student and a young man
through just,
you know, days ago.
And he was an American hero,
to be sure,
but one of the kindest peopl
that you could meet.
I mean, Seth, you know,
the type of person
who understands, again,
that there's strength,
that their power --
Because he was
a very powerful man.
But it wasn't that he
demanded or carried power.
He just was power.
He had powerful words.
He had a power that was born
out of a love of our country
a kindness,
and that gave him power,
and I'm gonna miss him so.
And, you know, one of the things
that I don't think has come ou
as much about him, but I want to
make a point of mentioning it,
he was very encouraging
of women,
and women in the professions
and women in leadership.
And so, you can, you know,
the stories of Diane Nash
or even the stories
that he would tell
about the other women
of the movement
that inspired him,
including Rosa Parks,
was one of the first people in
the movement who inspired him.
And I'm gonna miss him greatly
And I guess in a short way
of saying it, it's this.
John Lewis was about not onl
walking across
the Edmund Pettus Bridge
for the sake of voting right
and the fight
for equality in America.
He was about building bridges.
You know,
he wasn't about building walls
He was about building bridges.
He understood
the connection between people,
and he was a connecter.
He connected the fight
from the Civil Rights movement
in the '50s and '60s
to what he did standing
in the front of the line,
talking about what we need to do
around immigrants' rights,
that it's a civil-rights issue
He was a huge advocate
and fighter for LGBTQ rights
and marriage equality.
He transcended all of these eras
and periods of time
but always consistently
fighting for equality
and dignity for all people
-I know that you are now, as w
speak of dignity for all people,
oftentimes that is the cas
of having the money
to support your family,
put food on the table.
You were debating the $600
that's about to expire.
-Can you speak to why
that number is both economically
and morally sound?
And also, can you speak
to the argument that,
by giving Americans money,
we are disincentivizing them
to return to a workforce,
even though those jobs,
in most cases, aren't there?
-So, we have had
over 40 million people,
at one time or another
in the last few months,
lose their jobs.
Currently, we have a numbe
of about 17 million people
are currently unemployed.
Interestingly enough,
50% of African-American worker
are now unemployed
since the pandemic.
In June, Seth, 1/3 of American
were not able to pay
their housing costs,
rent or mortgage.
One in five mothers,
like I said earlier,
is describing her children under
the age of 12 as being hungry.
People are hurting in America,
hurting deeply.
And so what I am proposing
is that during the course
of this pandemic, until we hav
seen our way out of it,
there should be a moratorium
on evictions,
a moratorium on foreclosures
that there should be
a moratorium --
which means, basically,
a pause --
on turning off
people's utilities,
including their water service.
'Cause, by the way, people
can't pay their water bill
when they are not working,
and you need to wash your hand
to protect your family
from the virus.
So that's what my
R.E.L.I.E.F. Act calls for
just to give people relief
and let them just --
to the extent that we can,
survive through the course
of this pandemic so that,
at the end of it,
they can get back on their feet.
We don't want people
to fall further
and further through the cracks
Because at some point,
we need to recover.
And so let's see people
and carry them
through these days and these
months to get on the other sid
and with dignity.
-I do --
Because obviously this is
a very serious topic
we're talking about,
but on a lighter side,
I do want to compliment --
The R.E.L.I.E.F. Act
is an acronym.
I want to make sure
I get this right.
Rent Emergencies Leave Impacts
on Evicted Families Act.
Who comes up with
these acronyms, Senator?
-[ Laughs ]
There's, like, a whole group
of people
who work on those things.
It's really --
It's kind of part of
the funny art
of the United States Congress.
Like, there are people
who spend a lot of time
coming up with these acronyms,
and they're often very good.
-And, I mean, I guess the goal
of these acronyms is,
you want to make it so that,
you know --
And this is
either party would do this
You try to name it something
that you would
shame your colleagues
into voting against,
something like
the R.E.L.I.E.F. Act
or the C.A.R.E.S. Act or -
I mean, it seems to me
like you should try to make --
-The H.E.R.O.E.S. Act.
-The K.I.T.T.E.N. Act.
Just anything.
-Right.
No, right.
Like, I don't know that we hav
yet had the Santa Claus act,
but I think you're raising
a fair point.
-Yeah.
-I think -- but it is also about
speaking to the values
that are at play
in the legislation and certainly
with the R.E.L.I.E.F. Act,
it is --
that is a very important value
-Yes, that is a fair one.
The acronym does line up
with the core principles
behind the act.
-Yeah.
Yeah.